we have always feared houses powers were
too much for this world earth to Anna
and Elsa did you know your new movie is
totally connected to lots of other
Disney films it shouldn't be a big
surprise given that folks at Disney just
love to hide references and easter eggs
your canoe ride is certainly not
original on us and as for those mystical
looking rocks we're getting definite
deja vu vibes Rapunzel
Tarzan Merida Pocahontas yep it
certainly seems like you all exist in
the same Disney Cinematic Universe
where's our invitation we would love to
join you all in there the frozen two
trailers have given plenty of hints at
the movie links to lots of other Disney
films keep watching to the end to
discover how rock monsters and stones
connect on a now set to two other Disney
Princesses I won't let anything happen
to her
tangles floating lights in the official
frozen to trailer we see Elsa release a
load of diamond shape ice crystals
covered in mysterious rune symbols we
also see them floating in the air in the
teaser trailer with Anna looking at them
from the balcony they really remind us
of the lanterns entangled Rapunzel was
obsessed with those floating lights as
you'll recall the king and queen
launched the lanterns every year on
their daughter's birthday hoping that
they'd guide her home I should have
given it to you before but I was just
scared could these ice crystals be
trying to guide Elsa and Ana's parents
back home it would make sense for
tangled to be connected to frozen - as
Rapunzel and Eugene are seen arriving at
Elsa's coronation in the first movie the
Tarzan link there's also a theory that
connects frozen with Tarzan and there's
speculation that frozen - we'll take
this further director Chris buck
revealed his jokey theory that on an
Elsa's parents didn't die they survived
the shipwreck and queen Adina gave birth
to a son who is Tarzan and the frozen -
trailer has given fans more hope that
the King and queens fates are up for
discussion
babi doubts Elsa
is not what it seems as we cut to a shot
of Queen Adina looking out of a window
could that Tarzan Theory play out on
screen or at the very least will we
finally discover what really happened to
Elsa and Ana's parents
Pocahontas news canoe ride on an Olaf
take a ride in an ice canoe in the
full-length trailer were frozen - their
journey turns dangerous when they pitch
over the side of a waterfall does that
vertical fall remind you of another
Disney Princess yep
folk on us has been there done that in
her own movie specifically during the
song just around the Riverbend sure her
canoe was made out of wood not ice and
she enjoyed the ride unlike on an Olaf
who look totally panicked but you can't
deny the connection Epcot's frozen ever
after boat ride keeping with that canoe
it also has another intriguing Disney
connection although this one is related
to a theme park ride not a film in 2016
the Walt Disney World Resort opened a
boat ride called frozen ever after at
Epcot the leisurely boat ride through
arendelle includes a plummet down a
waterfall there were some controversy
surrounding the ride as it replaced fan
favorite Maelstrom so by including such
a similar scene in frozen to Disney's
proving that the frozen Everafter ride
has earned its place in Epcot mallanna's
Maui Josh GAD who voices Olaf got fans
all hyped up when he shared a photo of
himself in the cast on Instagram in
January 2019 he tagged Kristen Bell and
idina menzel kissing it a toy Sven but
he also tagged the reindeer as Dwayne
the rock Johnson that led to speculation
that Johnson will voice fun in frozen -
and that would give the sequel a big
connection with Mona's
since the rock voices maui however a fan
pointed out that maui shape-shifted into
svenne in the movie so maybe it was
simply a reference to that rise of the
guardians horses the spirit horses in
the frozen to trailer have certainly
made a big impression what do they
represent one thing's for sure they've
reminded some fans of the sinister black
horses called nightmares in the
DreamWorks movie rise of the guardians
Disney officially explains that the
horse in frozen 2 is a knock it's a
mythical water spirit that takes the
form of a horse using the power of the
ocean to guard the secrets of the forest
intriguing right zootopia's prediction
dizzy must have been planning this equal
for years and they had some fun with it
back in march 2016 when Zootopia was
released
Zootopia contains a huge amount of
Easter eggs and references to other
Disney films this specific one we're
interested in is the shot of Duke's
bootleg movies alongside Mia Juana aka
Moana and Drabek ake a gigantic there's
floats into which is obviously frozen
too it's only taken another three years
to get the movie ready braves poster
there's so much overlap between the new
frozen two poster and this brave poster
they're both misty and set against
forest backdrops the main characters are
standing in the center of the trees
ready for action Merida's crouching low
with our arrow drawn back while elsa and
anna are standing purposefully even
though this is thought to be a fan art
version two of the official brave
posters have the mist and trees and
positioning of the characters in common
with the frozen tube poster brave
standing stones on this subject of grave
eagle-eyed fans have noticed a major
connection between the frozen to trailer
and that 2012 movie it's the four huge
standing stones that emerge from the
mists towards the end of the trailer
they've got those mysterious rune
symbols on them and they're so
reminiscent of the standing stones that
feature prominently in four
the Pixar animators face the stones on a
circle that stands on the Isle of Lewis
it seems like the Disney animators work
on frozen to have taken the same
inspiration Elena
Vava Lars Rock Monster speaking of
stones at the end of the frozen -
trailer we also see Elsa hiding from
what looks like a giant rock monster in
Norse mythology there were monsters that
turned a stone when exposed to sunlight
but as Disney also taken inspiration
from its Latina princess Elena of avalor
there's a volcanic rock monster called
Charo in the Disney Channel TV show it
said he's based on a mythical creature
from Chilean mythology and we think he
totally connects Elena of avalor with
frozen to his rock monsters thanks to
his great stone body similar head shape
and huge size which of these Disney
connections did you spot which part of
the trailer are you most excited about
let us know in the comments please give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel for more great videos
like this one thanks for watching the
things we'll see you soon
[Music]